[Music]
for many babies this is all they have
the formula milk that's their daily
essential
but it's at the center of a scandal it's
a hidden problem that people find very
difficult to talk about
it's not a problem with the product
it's the price you have to pay for it
what happens behind closed doors
it's just frightening to think about
look at Amy's precious
the boy in the buggy has no idea but
he's part of it
his mum wanted to breastfeed but he
wouldn't latch on so he's entirely
reliant on formula the high prices are
driving his parents to do whatever they
can to keep him fed
we manage our money normally it's just
when we're really desperate
we'll do anything for him
even though it's break a little
it's that desperation that leads her
partner to go out and steal it in their
town in the southwest of England I hate
asking him to do it I really did it's
wrong
and it makes me feel horrible stealing
but you've got to do what's right for
him because he needs it can't give him
anything else
it's always on the edge and that you
never know what's going to happen next
your heart must be racing
it's scary
because there's always risk him being
arrested and not coming back and then
we're stuck then
the boy's father who hunts and gathers
like this agreed to speak to us
[Music]
his first solution had been watering
down his son's bottles of milk there was
one time where I was trying to make it
less than most I worked as much in as it
said to last out and you know what even
though he didn't react to it in my head
I was thinking
that I'm just going to steal him some
milk I shouldn't be stretching out for
him you know
now he doesn't go out without I mean
it's theft but I think it's criminal how
much they charge for this stuff if it
was a case of stealing or having your
baby go without you would steal I know
you would even you might hate it there's
no way you'd let him starve
new data that's monitored the baby
formula Market over the last two years
shows the average price is up by 24
percent
you can see on the supermarket shelves
just how much security is now in place
to deter shoplifters
because Healthcare professionals all
agree that breastfeeding is best for
babies formula milk is tightly regulated
and can't be discounted this isn't a
luxury product this isn't a product of
choice this is a necessary product that
is fundamental in the first six months
of a baby's life you know we put a lot
of focus on the need for breastfeeding
support quite rightly but that now needs
to be seen as a completely separate
issue to this all these things that are
happening are putting us on the brink of
a Public Health crisis this just
shouldn't be happening in 21st century
Britain this is a scandal
that warning of a Public Health crisis
is made worse because it seems it's
hidden
to find out why we went to the Northeast
to the baby Bank in Hartlepool can I
have some sixes please as soon as we
came in the doors you could just tell
how frantic you are yeah at the moment
thank you this has been the hardest week
we've ever had it's busier than ever
our formula demands are going through
the roof I will get messages on a
Wednesday and Thursdays and help I'm
running out of formula I've got this
much left and I don't get any money till
Monday
people are doing a lot of unsafe
practices to get hold of formula they
are swapping and chopping and changing
and we do not recommend that because
it's not good for digestion and it can
lead to health issues allergies but
they're looking at I'd rather baby had a
rash than starved and that's becoming
the reality for some families we've even
heard families using tubs of condensed
milk
that is not suitable for a number one it
is scandalous and it shouldn't be
happening we're in a modern country
we're in 2023 families shouldn't be
having to put themselves into dangerous
situations you really no doubt that
there are families who just
aren't able to put their hand up on us
for help no because of the shame the
stigma the fear of trolling the fear
that social services may get involved
the fear they may lose their child I'm
only hearing the tip of the iceberg for
sure what happens behind closed doors
it's just frightening to think about
further up the coast in Newcastle we met
a group of mums who told us what they've
been hearing
Amy has breastfed her daughter Hallie
and has felt lucky to be able to but she
knows what the price of formula milk is
doing
to so many other families I do know that
people put rusks into their babies
bottles
it's not recommended sometimes people
water down the formula I don't want to
prepare to that but they put extra water
in less powder that's also dangerous for
your baby because your baby's feeling
full but they're not actually getting
what they need it's tough because at the
time if you've got a crying baby and
you've got no formula you're gonna do
what you need to do
as his mum Sama knows so many families
who switched their babies onto cow's
milk early the guidelines say this
shouldn't happen before babies are 12
months old
they stop the cow milk because there is
cheaper one pound one pound something
you have like all purple do you know
families who are doing that at the
moment yeah a lot of families doing them
my friends and a lot of family doing
that nobody ever wants to say I can't
feed my kids nobody's ever gonna win any
honest I absolutely have to tell you
they're not going to tell you that and
I'm not saying I can't feed my kids but
I know that there are people that can't
and it's really tall
Dr Vicki Thomas is an infant feeding
specialist in this city and is worried
about where this leads I think it's
really frightening I think that we're
going to see an increase in infections
potentially life-threatening infections
I think that we're going to also see
babies who are being underfed or
possibly overfed so because they're
having a milk crammed into them when
they're not actually wanting or needing
it just because of the expense of making
up another bottle and it's been
described to us
as something that is on the brink of a
Public Health crisis is that too too far
no I think that's completely accurate I
think what we've got to remember is that
the nutrition that babies are receiving
right now determines their health going
forward for the next 80 years
it also leaves some families searching
online for cheaper options
it's known as formula foraging the
intentions Behind These ads might be
good it's too precious to go in the bin
but we've discovered containers that
have already been used and it's those
that really worry Emily it could have
been mixed with anything it could be
half a tub it could be out of date it
could be lid and with bacteria
and we're talking three six nine month
old babies now having really unsafe food
we wouldn't let adults do that why do we
let babies so that packet is actually
open yeah so this is a sale packet and
this is an open packet that mum's
already had some out of that shouldn't
be happening no I shouldn't it
it shouldn't be allowed that we're
selling open Formula because the health
risks for that child can be quite severe
this could be a baby who ends up in a e
needing a drip because they could get
such a bad stomach bug they could get
seriously dehydrated
it's horrendous
and there's a lot of it
it is appalling that we're having this
conversation that you are going out and
finding these kind of stories I think
there are some immediate actions that
can be taken absolutely I mean Healthy
Start vouchers no longer meet the cost
of a of a tub of formula milk and that
is a problem all first infant formulas
uh are nutritionally adequate that's
whether it's the cheapest version or the
most expensive ones and I think that's a
really important message to parents I do
think we should be looking at some of
the regulations around say for instance
the inability to collect or spend
loyalty points or vouchers which treats
formula milk in the same way as lottery
tickets or tobacco these are very
different products this is an essential
product and more broadly I think we do
need an inquiry we need to look at why
we are facing such high prices and you
know and and really investigate how we
ensure access to an affordable safe
product that families across the UK can
use
the formula milk manufacturers say they
realize how stretched family budgets are
but say their production costs have
significantly increased the Westminster
government also says it recognizes this
struggle and it is helping with the cost
of living there is though no plan to
increase the value of Healthy Start
vouchers
but when the health of British babies is
under threat like this
it can't lurk in the shadows any longer
Tom Parmenter Sky News